you were four separate races in family's
been a problem in various guises
certainly in the UK since digital TV
became popular in 1998 but it's more of
a problem now as we watch on different
devices perhaps the easy sings if we
demo it I've got the live tennis from
Wimbledon this is coming from the area
on top of the the roof where conditions
need to be cable or satellite does you
wouldn't make that much difference
although you do sometimes get delays
between the three of them if we bring up
the same thing on the BBC iPlayer which
is their online streaming service again
we're saying women to watch this live
and we see we've got a completely
different part of the match here and if
we were to watch it for long enough we
would see that this one was ahead of
this one probably by about 90 seconds to
two minutes so if you're watching on
your streaming via your device with us
your TV your phone or something you're
going to get a slightly delayed video if
I bring it up on another computer again
we're watching live by the iPlayer what
we find out is actually these two aren't
in sync
either is about a three-second delay by
something changing on here to there and
we can work out Sean can do some clever
things and work out the exact delay
between that screen and the streaming
one is this just because it's coming
across the internet it's got to go
through loads of suit yeah I mean these
is way to understand why this is
happening why we're getting those
dailies actually just have a think about
how streaming video work what's going on
to understand that probably works best
if we start how we get the picture from
the camera on the back there is a
connections here and the way that video
normally said these days is digital over
a signal called HD SDI and these run
depending on whether it's SD HD UHD it
can be as low as 270 megabits per second
or as high sort of 1.5 Giga bits or so
for HD and then for UHD you're talking
up to sort of 12 Giga bits although
sometimes that's carried over for
separate cables rather than one single
one when things were analog and
everything went over CRT type displays
like the one behind me things were dead
simple so we had a camera like so and we
had
TV or our display and effectively you
could connect to cable between the two
and this can would start producing the
image it would be scanning across the
top of the image or they would do the
next line and the next line and the next
line and so on well see the video on
interlace for how that's not actually
done as soon as it was started scanning
it would send a sync poster so this is
beginning of the line down the cable it
would then send the analog signal down
the cable and the CRT display could
start displaying that image on screen
effectively as soon as it saw the image
it was immediately displayed on screen
the delay was effectively the length of
the cable and the speed of light so
effectively zero on any sort of
terrestrial cable based thing and even
if we put an aerial in here as well as a
scenario and transmitted it and we had
some sort of receiver here to connect to
the TV again speed of light it was fast
enough so in the old days of analog TV
then everything what the camera saw
could be on your screen within a tiny
fraction of a second you would see it
live even if this was a digital link as
long as you're not starting to compress
it then you start me for example the SDR
connection on Shawn's camera we start
digitizing it we get sent along the same
thing would happen it would be
instantaneous things get more
interesting when we start to do digital
transmission because the bit rates as we
said are so high you're not going to
send 12 gigabits per second out over the
over-the-air you want to compress it and
reduce it and the way that that's
generally done is that you take hang on
I've got the perfect crop for this a
visual aid sort of before we had video
there was film anyway so the way that
the digital compression works rather
than working on a single frame it would
take say a region of so let's say 12
that's about 12 and we compressed them
together into a block now of course what
this means is is that if you've got to
compress the 12 all interrelated to each
other you've got to have all 12 frames
in here so you've got to wait while
those sort of series of frames come in
and so this is gonna delay the video by
well I say that's 12 frame that's about
half a second in UK 50 Hertz land if
that's all we did we would have a half
second delay in there cuz we'd have to
wait for that half second of video to be
captured into our compressor we can
press it and saying then we can send it
and then we can decompress it actually
there probably be some decompression
delay as we sort of decompressed it as
well but that would probably only be
another frame or so wouldn't be quite as
long as this now you could just do it on
those twelve and then you would take the
next twelve or so and compress that so
you'd end up with a half second delay
and so you can start to see where the
delay starts to come from in terms of
sending this thing actually what you
tend to find is it wasn't a half second
delay it was more like two or three
seconds you got and part of that was
that you'd actually want to try and do
more compress things in more than one go
so that if your first half second say
near needed slightly more bits to encode
it in the next half second needed
slightly less you could sort of Rob from
Peter to pay Paul to sort of manage to
dip bit rate over a period of time and
then you'd have to buffer it at the
other end to make sure everything works
so you're getting a delay because of the
way the compression works what about if
we start to do this over the Internet
well we've seen that we can send that
data down a network connection and get
it to display no problem at all but the
key difference here is that whereas when
it's transmitted over the TV it's
broadcast we send the signal once out of
the transmitter and anyone who's got a
receiving aerial can receive that signal
decode it and watch with a network
connection it's a point-to-point we send
the packets from one machine to another
machine yeah we can have broadcasts and
we can have multicast but in general
it's point-to-point we send it from one
machine to another the problem with that
is if you want more than one person to
watch it then you need more than one
stream so you've got the computer which
is connected to the camera or the TV
network system there so the video is
going into that and then it's got a
network connection and for something
like the iPlayer that's about five
it's per second and that's sending it
out to my computer
yeah but then Sean decides he's fed up
of filming this computer file he wants
to know what the tennis is doing so he
connects his computer to it again that's
another five megabits a second there and
so on and so on suddenly this machine is
now going to produce ten megabits so
we're getting a problem here is the more
streams we add we have to send it out
multiple times this is a bandwidth issue
it's a bandwidth issue yeah it takes
five megabits per stream if we want two
streams that's ten megabits four streams
that's 20 and so on
up until 100 megabit card you can
probably at 20 streams and so on so what
what do we need to do what we could put
another computer in here another server
and feed the video and then we could
actually start adding other people and
load balancing them to get there and so
on and if we're very clever what we'd
actually do is we start moving these
computers to be closer to where the
users are so using less of the network
and so what we could do is actually have
this computer here say it was in my
local ISP it could just take the same
data coming from this one and send it on
to Shawn's computer and you can send it
on to my computer here and then perhaps
the break is as well when Australia were
playing and so actually we now have five
megabits from this and five from each of
these because it can copy the easy out
to each of them and of course this is
going to increase a delay slightly but
it's going to be marginal so you can't
really make anything that's not
explaining why we get those delays so we
need to build up lots of machines
transmitting it move them closer the
problem with this approach is that we
were sending data from the encoding
computer to Brady's machine my machine
Shawn's machine how do we make sure that
the packets we want to send here get to
these machines particularly is the way
or to do is they were using a system
called UDP not the standard TCP that was
doing there and you had issues with
people's firewalls getting in the way so
the way they got around that was I think
Apple first came up with a thing called
HTTP Live Streaming that is equivalents
from a daisy Microsoft and standard that
tends to be used now is something called
mpeg-dash dynamically adaptive streaming
over HTTP and the the way this works is
sort of on a sort of bigger scale
version of what we saw happening at the
lower end if we imagine what we're
watching whether it's a video recorded
like this YouTube video or something
that's happening live we can think of
there being time involved yeah and we
start off and it continues playing up
until some point the idea is rather than
sending it as warm long continuous
stream like we were doing earlier as he
said well okay let's break it up into a
series of segments and let's break it up
say every three or four seconds we
encode a segment that is three seconds
long we encode another segment that is
three seconds long so that takes up to
six seconds another segment that's three
seconds long nine seconds and so on now
we just break the video up into
three-second jokes be a lot more film
but you get the idea
and what we do is we encode that first
chunk into a compressed video file say
mpeg-4 doesn't really matter which one
it is you use and you get a file just
like if you compress the video on your
computer and then you put that file onto
the web and you tell your client to
download that file from the web so it
does an HTTP GET request for that file
after three seconds we can encode this
file that will take some amount of time
let's say it takes wait you wanted to
take less than three seconds hopefully
but it takes some amount of time to
encode that then we download it put it
on the web server we download and of
course we can reuse all the content
delivery networks that we've already got
in place for the web to distribute this
out as we're going so this can then get
that file and while this is then playing
out this file here and of course there's
going to be three seconds later we can
do the same thing with the next chunk we
can encode that we get another segment
of the thing and we put that onto the
web as well and we stretch this one so
we can then start playing that one out
as soon as this video has finished
playing so play the first three seconds
and then we start playing back for the
next one and the process repeats until
we get to the end of our video so this
explains why the two
player ones were out of sync with each
other because this one we study first is
started playing from this junk and we've
got some way through it when we saw the
next one it started playing from the
beginning of that junk and so we got up
to sort of three seconds worth of delay
and if we just go back we can actually
see those chunks arriving I'm looking at
what my web browser is doing the
debugger built into Safari so if we
watch there at the bottom as we start
the video playing so you can see it
continuing updating as each bit of this
file comes in and is downloaded m4s so
what does that mean well that's just a
little bit of that playing with you it's
not quite fully doesn't have all the
heavy stuff unknown things so the moment
we've got the video playing and it's
playing at 2.9 megabits per second in
2009 if I fullscreen it we will see in a
second that it will switch from the 2.9
megabits section to the 5 megabit
version it's just drop that so it's just
wrong so for some reason there's
something on the network there's more
people watching it maybe the people are
downloading things here at the
University so it's actually you said I'm
struggling to get the 2.9 Meg's dream
I'm going to drop down to the 1.7
megabits per second stream so the moment
we just assume that this is actually
encoding for one video stream so we've
seen them coming in but you can actually
be really clever here because as we saw
in that demo there that actually your
network conditions aren't always fixed
if they're not always sending a 5
megabits per second you can't
necessarily always do that even when
you've got a gigabit connection onto the
internet like we've got here
what you can do with this sort of
approaches as well as the encoding a
high-resolution version you can also
encode a slightly smaller version and an
even smaller version of that
and then if the computer realizes that
when it gets to this one that it can't
download the large version it could say
okay I'm going to pull the small version
down and actually play the smaller
version here and as long as you make
sure that all the segments line up they
start at the same point they finish at
the same point then you can dynamically
hence the - switch between them so that
you're always able to play the video
even if the quality is going up and down
depending on the network connections
that are fluctuating ok we can see why
we get
three-second delays we wait to encode
those videos and we can see why we get a
sort of delay between the two because we
have to start at the beginning of one of
the segments although there are ways you
can jump in but even then if you think
about it if I start watching it and jump
in here I have to start playing from
here and I have to start downloading all
this bit first
but Shaun starts watching at this point
where he only has to download that bit
so you will get some variability there
within general that's why we get
variations in it why do you sometimes
see this to be 90 seconds delayed from
actual real time the answer is probably
quite boringly simple in that to make
sure all this works to make sure that
the video is all available on all the
web servers and they're passed out to
all the different content delivery
network servers close to where the
clients are rather than being stored at
the server
wherever the video is being encoded is
that you'll put in a certain amount of
buffering both at the server end so that
you will encode several things and then
have them being passed out while others
are being encoded with a delay so that
you one gets delayed for some reason you
can catch up but also you do the same
thing in your client you'd client with
buffer things up so he knew hang on I
can't download this one which is taking
too long I can switch to the lower one
and hopefully have time to get it and
switch to the other one before you'd
notice it was sort of stuttering on the
display you just continue playing it so
the basically reason why is it there's a
heck of a lot of buffering going on
while you're just waiting for things to
sort of buffer up you know waiting for
things to be downloaded storing them in
your memory and then playing them out
after a certain amount of time surely
the more people that use streaming as
opposed to broadcast the worse this
problems going to get before it gets
better right so it's probably not really
related to the number of people because
the more people you are the more servers
you need but you then you just fan out
at different points so it's probably the
number of clients watching probably
won't make any difference to the actual
delays more just the buffering time
that's built into the processes but if
we hit play on a live stream yeah we
wait maybe a few seconds and it played
yes so that's our buffer all of the rest
of it really is happening at the
encoding but the thing is
that your buffers you start somewhere
what video father you actually start
playing back with so you can imagine
that you've got the current three
seconds of being encoded perhaps you've
got sort of three or four minutes worth
that you can go if not further back so
you can rewind the video streams and so
on you might start there and start
pulling them down faster I mean we're
encoding at five megabits I can pull
things down at one gigabit here so I
will download those files very very
quickly so I might start reading several
in so and I told Ashley if I go down
this quickly I might catch up a bit but
yeah a lot of it is in the server and
making sure that it's all encoded and
then split up sent out to all the
servers and so on and that happens
before the client needs them of course
the simple thing would be the best way
for transmitting live video over the
Internet is if you only have to send the
package out once and then it was copied
to everyone who actually wanted to
receive it which is what happens when
you broadcast it from the aerial you can
actually do that there is a technology
called multicast and networks support
things called broadcast but it's it's
actually fraught with all sorts of
interesting complexities your rooters
have to support it to make sure that it
actually gets to the right point it has
some interesting effects with Wi-Fi
because you have to guarantee that every
machine on the network can receive it
regardless of how far away they often
the Wi-Fi base station so you have to
transmit it at the slowest rate that the
Wi-Fi base station supports so they can
all receive it and so on so actually
it's it will probably happen will
probably come to a point where this is
or multicast out where each machine
receives copies of the one packets being
sent out but I think that's probably two
or three years away even though the
technology has been around for several
years
and only we can decrypt the whole
message because we have all the keys
what's really interesting is the
property that this gives us the first
thing is that k2 doesn't need to know
anything except we address of k1 and the
address of k3 it doesn't need to know
who I am right it receives a message